première question qui est évidente est
ce qu'il ya des choses qu'on ne peut pas
dire à un enfant ou est-ce qu'il faut
absolument tout dire
alors tous dira certainement pas mais en
tout cas leur parler de tout ce qui les
concerne ça oui donc ce qui les concerne
c'est ce qui va changer quelque chose
dans leur vie quotidienne
c'est aussi ce qui va changer quelque
chose dans l'atmosphère familiale
ici il ya des émotions compliqué un
drame dans la vie familiale
évidemment il faut dire quelque chose
parce que vous dites qu'ils ressentent
le nom le nom dis le nous et non verbale
où il n'a changé ou de même un film
d'atmosphère
absolument et ce qui concerne leur
origine c'est aussi vous et votre les
instants notamment en revanche à des
choses effectivement qui ne les
concernent pas et en particulier la vie
affective ou sexuelle des parents
on a coutume de dire que le droit de
savoir des enfants s'arrêtent devant la
porte de la chambre des parents
on en parlera notamment avec caroline
cas une question à ce sujet si je ne me
trompe pas thibault d'abord à une
question posée il faut que je vous avoue
j'ai tendance à parler hyper hyper
librement mais très librement en
présence d'enfants en bas âge très bas
âge qui sont les parages dans la pièce
et en lisant votre livre j'ai compris
qu'en fait ils saisissent où ils
comprennent des choses ils sont c'est
vrai ou pas qu'est ce qui se passe je
racontais en présence de tout petits de
deux trois quatre ans dont on se dit
qu'après tout ils perçoivent pas la
teneur exacte de nos propos alors les
enfants d'aujourd'hui sont extrêmement
informé on parle effectivement très
librement devant eux
effectivement ils vont pas comprendre le
sens de tous les maux que vous allez
employés et curieusement malgré cette
parole très libre on constate qu'il ya
des sujets qui demeure tabou et que des
sujets effectivement qui vont marquer
l'histoire familiale où la vie familiale
al'inverse ne vont pas être abordée
voilà et c'est aussi l'objet de ce livre
c'est pouvoir trouver les mots pour
parler d'événement aussi parfois
douloureux ou compliquer les mets donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut quand même tout
de même malgré tout même si l'on se dit
qu'il ne comprenne pas faire attention à
ce qu'on raconte en leur présence alors
oui c'est à dire que par exemple parlé
très librement de sexualité devant les
enfants tout petit n'est pas forcément
une très bonne idée parce que ça va
venir peut-être faire effraction dans
leur imaginaire c'est des
représentations qu'ils n'ont pas encore
et voilà du coup c'est attention car
voilà vous avez compris thibault je vais
me calmer je le fais avec elle descend
d'un étage
emilie alors est ce que quand on est un
couple on peut se disputer devant devant
ses enfants
et deuxième chose comment parler divorce
avec ses enfants parce qu'il ait fait
toujours un peu un peu compliqué oui
alors est ce qu'on peut se disputer
disons plutôt que ça arrive parfois oui
voilà et que quand ça arrive
effectivement il faut pouvoir mettre des
mots dessus c'est à dire dire bah écoute
tu nous as entendu hier soir
effectivement ça criait fort c'est
compliqué dès fois entre nous voilà
mettre des mots sur ce qui s'est passé
ça c'est très important de façon de
rassurer l'enfant
oui c'est ça revenir dessus le rassurer
sur le fait qu'il n'est pas responsable
de la dispute de ses parents parce
qu'ils ont toujours l'impression qu'ils
sont au centre du monde
donc voilà et puis pour la question du
divorce
c'est important d'en parler à partir du
moment où on sait comment les choses
vont se dérouler c'est dire que ce qui
va être important pour un tout petit
enfant c'est de savoir qu'est-ce qui va
se dérouler pour lui et dans la suite
des choses très concret très concret
c'est sûr que si on n'en est pas encore
là
dire simplement on va se séparer mais
sans savoir quand sans savoir où on va
habiter sans savoir si on va déménager
ou pas et c'est ça ça va le prestige et
dans un tiroir ya plein de sous
questions qui ne sont pas abordés c'est
carrément d'accord très bien caroline
vous l'avais dit à un instant le droit
de savoir des enfants s'arrêtent à la
porte des parents mais si par exemple un
soir par mégarde il ya un petit peu de
bruit dans cette chambre
nu devant des tout petits est-ce que
c'est très grave
êtes-vous premier venu à la maison
franchement la nudité chez moi ça ne
fait pas c'est pas quelqu'un de
dangereux
ouais c'est pas un tabou c'est pas ça
qui m'arrêtent alors s'ils ont entendu
des bruits on dit quoi on faisait du
bricolage sa rappelle alors s'ils ont
entendu des bruits et qui vous pose des
questions bas effectivement vous pouvez
dire que voilà vous étiez ensemble et
que vous passiez un moment agréable et
que peut-être vous avez fait un peu de
bruit en tout cas ce que pour par
rapport à la question de la nudité
jusqu'à l'âge de deux ans en fait les
enfants n'ont pas de perception visuelle
de la différence sexuelle c'est à dire
que effectivement ils vont pas percevoir
le sexe d'homme le sexe de femme l'ait
fait pour eux c'est ça me pose aucune
question
ça ne pose pas de question en tout cas
voilà six mois leurs parents se promener
nu devant eux cela va pas leur poser de
questions à peu près jusqu'à l'âge de
deux ans après effectivement ils vont
réaliser que le sexe de maman n'est pas
le même que celui papa effectivement à
ce moment là d'abord ça nécessite des
explications
et puis voilà je pense que la pudeur la
construction de la pudeur c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important pour pour
l'enfant donc voilà il faut y penser ce
qu'il veut dire que vous conseillez tout
de même aux parents de se rhabiller
je me dis allez oui dans verte à dire
comme ça mais oui c'est un peu ça car on
sort habitat après 2
après deux ans de carrière des bébés et
même peut-être un vampire d'écossé voilà
en tout cas après bientôt un oui ok bien
jimmy un autre un autre thème je crois
que c'est la mort voix oui comment
aborder la mort avec un enfant lorsqu'il
ya un décès dans la famille et puis à
partir de quel âge peut-on faire alors à
tous les âges à n'importe quel âge c'est
à dire que un des points importants
c'est justement d'avoir à l'idée de ne
pas attendre que les enfants comprennent
les mots pour leur dire les choses parce
que c'est une manière aussi de nous
habituer nous alors parlé de tous les
sujets la question de la mort quand il
ya un décès dans une famille et bien
effectivement les gens vont être tristes
on va parler on va pleurer et si on ne
dit pas quelque chose à l'enfant de ce
qui est en train de se passer c'est un
peu comme s'il avait un film sans les
sous titres on va dire qu'il a besoin
aussi de comprendre pourquoi tout d'un
coup tout le monde se met à pleurer
pourquoi on passe des coups de téléphone
etc mais pardonnez moi quand vous dites
il a besoin de mots quelle mouche on
utilisait ce qu on utilise la métaphore
il est au ciel
il nous a quittés où il est parti parce
qu'on a peut-être le sentiment qu'il
peut revenir enfin voyez ce qu'il faut
expliquer la finitude c'est à dire c'est
fini et ça ne reviendra plus ou bien
est-ce qu'il faut rester dans une sorte
de métaphore un peu poétique
alors je pense qu'il faut utiliser les
mots qui désignent la chose à dire dire
il est mort où elle est morte quand même
s'ils utilisent le mot on utilise le mec
parce qu'effectivement la métaphore pour
un enfant de moins de 6 ans c'est
quelque chose de compliqué le mot est
pris au pied de la lettre
donc mami est parti habiter dans les
étoiles eh ben effectivement il ya des
enfants qui regardent le ciel pour voir
si par hasard ils vont apercevoir leur
mamie dans les étoiles
donc je pense que c'est très important
d'utiliser les mots qui désignent la
réalité voilà on a des mots pour ça et
il faut il faut pouvoir les utiliser et
compris avec les tout-petits